you competing in 2008
i was uh i became a fan of yours uh at
that moment and since then
i uh i kind of knew about judo my
university had a judo club and i kind of
knew about jiu jitsu from
martial arts
and obviously i wrestled for many years
before and i love wrestling
but there's something about you
competing that made me
well there's no other way to say but it
like changed the direction of my life
because it it forced me
to say you know what i'm going to start
judo in jiu jitsu
and first of all for that i'm really
grateful but it's fascinating to think
because this kid who's 22 years old i'm
sure i'm not the only one
that you've influenced like you've
changed the direction of my life
and there could be
a huge number of others like that i mean
that's the power of
you as an individual at the on the
olympic stage
you ever think about the pressure of
that did you did you think it's a 22
year old there's a bunch of people
like i know i'm not the only one who
changed i just happened to have him like
a microphone recently
you know what i mean like is that
it's fascinating to think about right
like you
perhaps you didn't think about this it's
just
just a judo match but you're like you
influenced
hundreds of thousands of people if not
millions is that interesting
it's
it's not something that really
hit me until
um
2012 when i lost
because that's when like
i would say like the world felt bad for
me
at that point and that's when you knew
that like
people were watching
and people were inspired by the loss
because of how much went into that match
yeah
because you know the 99 of us who
watched it thought i won
except for the one percent of the people
who were considered judges at that day
in the event
so but i mean that's the the win or lose
that that was a really inspiring match
and that's when that's when it dinged
that like
because i don't i don't watch something
and really get inspired by like the
person and the act
it's like it's an accumulative thing
but for a lot of people like
when they watch how much goes into it
and then when i broke down on the match
like the amount of suffering
that happens when you lose a match like
that and then
you know really coming back in
winning in rio
there's a trend of people who were
inspired
that knew about london and then when
they found out i won in rio
that's when like people like
in droves felt like they could overcome
their own personal obstacles to still
achieve something because they've
witnessed somebody who's fallen
and gotten back up
yeah but it's not something that
you think about like on the day
it's when you look back and you go oh
cause and effect
i wonder if you can comment on that i'm
trying to realize and live up to
the fact that there's like young people
that come up to me
and i'm starting to realize like
certain words i say will have a long
lasting impact on them yep because you
say it is like
you don't even doesn't just yeah the win
some of them might come back 30 years
later and a word i said was the reason
they quit a thing and started the new
thing that led them to become their true
self like
define success all that kind of stuff
like on the flip side though some people
based on the actions that we do today
even with this cast
will alter the course of their lives
forever i had a guy one time
was it after london
it must have been after london
he actually found me on instagram
wrote me what seemed to be like a
dissertation on instagram about how much
he i disrespected him
14 years earlier because
i didn't step on a podium to take a
picture after winning a tournament where
he bronzed
yeah and i'm thinking to myself like
at the time like
having dinner with my family because i
had to leave the next morning was more
important to me as a person
not thinking about
who you potentially will become
and
the
actions of whatever you do today
if you do become quote unquote famous or
somebody in a spotlight that that could
come back to bite you
to me i don't know about you that that's
that's super motivating like
not to be
a lesser version of myself
ever
yeah just be on top of your game
whatever that game is be on top of your
game when you're interacting with people
and when you're just in your own private
life
i'm trying to make sure that i'm the
exact same person privately as i am
publicly and like making sure i'm on
point i see like just hanging out with
uh joe rogan a lot i see how he's first
of all the exact same person
and second he he like walks around and
there's like a huge number of fans and
you'll just take pictures and like it is
very cool and it's very cognizant of
like certain words he says especially
young people like they're going to take
that and that's going to be a memory for
them for a couple years yeah that might
be influential for the rest of their
life so yeah
i don't know that's a cool
responsibility
not to it up hey but but anyway i i
bring all that up to just say
thank you
uh so even if you like were frustrated
that you didn't win a medal at least at
least uh
you influenced one
silly russian kid
to get into the martial arts and what
happens when you get into martial arts
it alters the direction of your life
yeah mine from for for the better
you